The next term we want to talk about is the random variable.
First let's go back to experiments and
outcomes. There are some experiments whose outcomes
are not numeric.
Flipping a coin is such an example.
when you flip a coin
the result is heads or tails.
This type of data is not going
to help us.
I mean the fact that it is heads and tails. So if
we have a file or an X like
an Excel sheet or a CSV file and we
have heads and tails. We cannot perform statistical
calculations on the word head.
Underwood heads on the wood tails
statistics is arithmetic.
Right statistics if you
want to calculate the mean average we need to work
with numbers.
So the word heads and the word Tails must
be converted somehow to a number.
Because once we have a numeric representation, we
can calculate mean median mode standard deviation
Etc.
We can learn.
things about our data
that's what a random variable does.
If you look here.
This is what we call a map.
in mathematics
a map
is
a general concept of a function
But this is what this notation means.
in
statistics and the probability Theory random variables
are expressed usually with an uppercase
that are X.
this colon
means that it takes you from one set of values to another set
of values.
So we are defining a map X.
That takes you from one set of values. This is the Greek letter
Omega Capital Omega.
And this is convention.
In many textbooks and
papers literature you
will see them use the uppercase letter.
Or the capital Omega to represent the sample space,
right? So this
set of this set of sets.
Will be represented with the Greek letter Capital Omega.
So the X will map values from
the sample space to values.
in the set of real numbers
Why do we do this? Well?
suppose our sample set
We have two possible outcomes heads and
tails.
What the random variable do?
Is it will convert for example h?
To the number one.
and T to number 0
so it will convert the data type so to speak.
Once we convert the data type from string to
integer to use programming terminology, right?
If we have alphanumeric characters.
You can convert that to excuse me
if you have.
Alpha or if you have letters and special
characters, you can convert them to numbers to an
integer or float. For example.
that's what a random variable is essentially doing it is converting
non-numerical values to numerical values because once we
have these numerical values
we can perform arithmetic.
And compute their mean average.
And yeah, basically perform statistics on
these quantities.
Let's say you perform for experiments.
with four outcomes
you flip a coin four times.
You get heads and then heads and then tails
and then Tails see that's a set.
What do we call a set of outcomes?
event
So the letter A here represents this event.
And when we say that X is a map.
and here we are expressing it as a
with function notation
if we were to take a and plug it into X.
What we will do is we will map.
the values
that are not numerical to numerical values
to real numbers.
And of course a is a subset.
Of the sample space, right?
Up here we set that.
an event an event
Is a subset of the sample space?
so for example, this is a
and then we have B.
Okay.
Let's say there's a b but I haven't written it down. So we have two two events
A and B.
A and B are both subset of
the sample space
Anyway, what the X random variable will do
is it will map.
the values in the event
two values in
the real number elements in the real number
and from here we can perform.
arithmetic algebra so on
and then we have a probability function.